[Music]
foreign
[Music]
on November 6th the token's value began
to fall losing more than 80 percent of
its worth in the span of 72 hours looks
like we got a situation on our hands
regulators
Mount up it was a clear black night he
was sitting at home looking at a JPEG on
his trusty iPhone it was a rare nft of a
hipster Mouse so he did what you do he
mortgages house and he put in a bid he
was getting it he couldn't sit there
while he saw those other people get rich
but then the market crashed the value
deflated this shouldn't be allowed they
should regulate it he saw a JPEG it
looked in demand so he mortgaged his
house spent 400 Grand we need to pass
new laws to prevent this thing he
wouldn't be so dumb if we regulate yeah
what um
[Music]
that's not a hundred percent what I was
talking about
I mean the first part was was okay but
it's more like it was a cool crisp day
he was watching the game that's when he
saw a commercial with folks of Acclaim
crypto returns that'll never default so
he thought what you think that sounds
too good to be false mortgage this house
research the rate checked out the CEO
nothing seemed out of place but when he
checked one morning the value was gone
we should make fraud illegal this is all
just wrong he did his research and he
studied up and bought invisible tokens
it's got just made up it was a harsh
consequence for an honest mistake his IQ
wouldn't be five if we regulate you know
on the message boards for the nfts I'm
one of the smarter people so
foreign
you do the math
it was a lukewarm noon he's on Capitol
Hill cause he got margin called and was
facing a bill you don't understand I've
lost all that I had you need to pass
more laws this is terribly bad excuse me
thanks for letting me join but isn't
part of the issue him there's a new dog
coin maybe the underlying Tech is when
we shouldn't for stall it's possible one
day
he wouldn't have the impulse control of
a toddler Wicked and human nature with
the pencil today why do I have a feeling
that they're gonna regulate
[Music]
Literacy By the way have you seen the
state lottery the powerball's 1 billion
you better not win he's gonna make good
decisions when we regulate
[Music]